-Hey, everyone, it is time
for "Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtag ♪
♪ Hashtag ♪
♪♪
-Now, we do this thing
every week where I send out
a hashtag and I ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
So since they just announced
the "Sex and the City" reboot,
I sent out a hashtag,
"Describe a TV show badly,"
where I asked you guys
to take a TV show
and then give it a funny
or weird summary.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic.
All day, by the way.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trended all day.
Thank you for playing along.
We appreciate that, guys.
And now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"Describe a TV show badly"
responses from you guys.
This first one
is from @GumGumerson.
Hey, we know @GumGumerson.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Ice latte for Don Snow?"
[ Laughter ]
"Don Snow?
So, sorry -- Jon Snow?"
[ Laughter ]
Thanks.
This one's from @ReneeJordan78.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @Elyssa09618818.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
"This looks cute --
Oh, cover your eyes!"
This one's from
@breannebuchanan.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @mekimba.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @BillWanyama1.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
-Yes!
Yes.
♪♪
Winner.
-That's funny, man.
This one's from @roychow80.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @ItsMikeHill.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @BeingValentina.
She says...
It's like,
"Oh, I guess he never did.
You're right."
This one's from @JoAnnNJ1.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
This one's from
@JakeWilliamsArt.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @AlZebooker.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
That's funny, man.
Yeah, the show
was ahead of its time, man.
This one's from @JohnThomp.
That's a good name, huh?
-John Thomp.
-Yeah, action hero.
-Yeah, you know
who you got to call.
-Who?
-John Thomp.
-Pwfff!
-Pwff!
-Dude, "Anything but that."
-That's what he says?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"You have to accept
one of these missions."
"Anything but that."
[ Laughter ]
"That sounds scary."
"But you're John Thomp."
"I don't do --
I'm afraid of heights."
[ Laughter ]
"John Thomp is afraid of --"
"Yeah,
and I'm allergic to cats."
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @JohnThomp101.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
Oh, that hurts.
-I bet.
-That hurts.
-This last one's
from @gregcherrybrand.
He says...
There you have it.
[ Laughter ]
Those are
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.